Nhanh Hà Minh mốt tháng 1 năm 2020, có quan cạnh rất đều trà công an tính án dạm cho biết
đã thí hành vệ bắt bị cán để tạm dạm dạm dạm dạm dạm chân chí vi, sinh ngăn Hà nghị khu trận linh năm
buộc phương dạm, tính án dạm, đều trà về hình vi hiếp dâm ở dưới mùi sảo tuổi.
Thao kết quả đều trà bàn đầu, chân chí vi là nhân viên dấu hàng, siper, gió thường suyên được推 đi mua đồ
cho em bờ, sinh ngăn Hà nghị khu trận linh bốn, nên viên quảnh biết phà nhấn tin qua ử dụng dạ lồ với mờ.
Tháng 1 năm Hà nghị khu trận linh năm 2020, vi hẹn mờ đi trơ dồi dụ giống, đưa mờ đến nhà
của một hơi quên của vi và thực hiện hình vi xâm hại mờ ngăn bồn Hà nghị khu trận Hà nghị lắm.
Cô với thu đoạn tương tự, vi tích tục hình vi xâm hại mờ số đó mờ đã kể lại sự việc trong người
tân ngàn và dạ dình đã chính báo đến cơ quan công an. Hình cơ quan kể rất đều trà công an tính án dạm
tục đưa trà làm só, sử lý kêu quy định pháp lượt.